welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and Loki season 2's new breakout
character is Ora Boris AKA OB played by
KIU Quan the oneman crew of the repairs
and advancement Department of the time
variance Authority but in a TVA that
we're now learning has had several past
memory wipes and resets among its
Workforce why do Mobius and the others
have no memory of meeting OB but OB
remembers all of them why was he exempt
from all the memory wipes I'm going to
explain why OB is simultaneously the
most important employee of the TVA but
also Al the one hidden from the others
why OB is really the OG in fact that
might be why Mobius had that nickname
for him so season 2 episode one is
actually titled Orab Boris which is
appropriate because the term comes from
the mythological figure of a snake
eating its own tail and structurally
this episode is exactly that Loki in a
future time period trying to extract
himself from time to cure his time
slippage and miraculously managing to
Circle back home upon himself but only
after being pruned by some mystery
figure and I didn't want to point this
out but it it's going around enough and
it is visible plainly in episode one but
skip to this time if you don't want to
know who might have pruned Loki until
this season reveals it if you look
behind Loki in that future version of
the TVA in the shadows of the hallway
behind him you do see a figure that I
thought might be Ren Slayer but no if
you do brighten it up it does look like
a version of Loki that we've seen in
trailers starting to wear that TVA
jacket it looks like a future version of
Loki is pruning his past self to close
the loop but despite the structural
logic of calling this episode Ora Boris
the titular character is not revealed
until 21 minutes in which I should point
out is the exact midpoint of the
episode's 42-minute runtime minus
credits Mobius in this episode is
bewildered to learn that there was ever
a past era of the TVA believing that
time passes differently in the TVA but
clearly not understanding that there was
some era before the understanding that
the timekeepers were in charge on the
way down to visit the RNA Department of
the TVA Mobius says I have no memory of
having my memory wiped I Lov it it's
such a good joke but then they enter the
RNA department and Mobius says it's been
a while since I've been down here
actually I'm not sure I've ever been
down here this to me was such an odd
line because Mobi seemed to have the
muscle memory to know where to take Loki
to get his time slipping checked out but
upon entering this room suddenly
realized he didn't actually know where
he was like subconsciously his body must
have known where to take him even if he
consciously didn't remember where or why
I mean hey people of a certain age can
probably relate to this feeling and this
is a common workplace Behavior among
drones who have just worked at the same
place for several years of their lives
the series Ence explores this in a
really fun way you're just kind of
walking down a hallway and you don't
really realize why you're walking down
it until you're already there but this
gets further explored as Mobius fails to
remember Obi but Obi remembers him wow
wa to see you again how long has it been
could it be three or four 400 years
remember you got off on the wrong floor
and I told you it was the wrong floor
wait that's right yes because then I
stayed for a little bit he took me over
he left immediately and Obie even
attributes his nickname of OB to Mobi
coming up with it he calls me OB yeah so
again if the memories of all TVA
Employees were wiped to make them forget
about the previous era when he remains
ruled openly which sounds like would
have included an instance between Mobius
and OB 400 years prior a very very brief
exchange that would have included Mobius
making a joke about shortening or Boris
to OB why was Obi left out of that
memory wipe so that he remembers Mobius
well in general Obie does seem to be the
Forgotten member of the TVA Workforce
you could say perhaps he remains just
forgotten was down there like his office
is down a series of elevators and a part
of the TVA rarely visited he gets zero
visitors I pointed out how even the
final elevator to his office has several
pneumatic tubes right there so that
people don't even have to take those
final steps to send their work orders to
him I compared him to Milton from Office
Space after Lumberg relocates him to the
basement and initech forgot that they
had fired him but more than that I think
Obie is something closer to olivander
the wand maker from Harry Potter or the
Half Blood Prince potions textbook
Scribbler an overlooked but critically
important Artisan who propels everything
forward not the OB the OG new rockstars
viewers have been hearing me mention
raycon for years the wireless earbuds
that start at half the price of other
premium audio Brands but this is
definitely the first time you've heard
me say this happy birthday raycon you're
turning six to celebrate their birthday
raycon is offering 20 to 40% off across
their entire site so raycon earbuds come
in a range of colors patterns and
options for fit none of which have
dangling wires or stems that can get
caught on stuff rayon's everyday earbuds
are known for delivering highquality
audio and thoughtful features like a
32-hour battery life and a perfect inear
fit for all day wear and Lasting Comfort
I wear them whenever I'm out of the
house and if it weren't for being able
to hear my audiobook perfectly no matter
how much Street noise there is I
wouldn't even notice I had them in
they're super comfortable and I'm not
the only one who thinks so rayon's
already racked up 78,000 fstar reviews
you can control your earbuds with simple
tap functions so it's easy to toggle
between three customizable sound
profiles noise noise isolation and
awareness mode and if you already have a
pair of raycon earbuds that you love
there's more to check out this past year
raycon expanded with the introduction of
raycon home and raycon power Tech
there's a lot to celebrate celebrate
raycon turning six with their biggest
sale of the Year going on now hurry now
to buy raycon.com neww rockstars and use
code birthday to get 20 to 40% off
sitewide and thanks again to raycon for
sponsoring this and making something
great because the first episode also
establishes that it was OB who wrote the
TVA guide book there's one on every desk
at the TVA it's a detailed index of
every mechanical classification and
maintenance routine in each sector on
each device and inside every computer
program with the TVA I wrote it myself
now from a purely functional standpoint
he remains may have just left OB with
his memory intact because he needed at
least one TVA employee who knew how
everything works just to keep everything
well oiled and chugging along like Obi
does indicate that he shared some
responsibilities with Miss minutes don't
get down here too much I guess I never
had to Miss Mes took care of everything
I just ran diag tics every few hundred
years it seems like he remains has
automated as much of the TVA as he could
with Miss minutes but needs one human
worker I.E one with a soul or a temporal
Aura no offense Miss minut some worker
on the ground to check up on everything
now that miss minut is offline and
Sylvie broke the sacred timeline the
temporal Loom became overwhelmed but it
also tells you that he remains must have
kept OB there for some other reason
because if it was just to keep
everything chugging along they wouldn't
need Mis minutes or anything else to fix
that Loom Obie says that he wrote the
TVA guide book and a quick flash of it
in the closing credits proves that the
name gorab Boris is actually printed on
the cover of the book this is a big deal
Obie said that these are on every desk
of the TVA this guide book you could say
are like the sacred Jedi texts of the
TVA they're the Bible and he remains is
allowing someone else to retain visible
authorship of that Bible like this TVA
has been carefully designed to appear
tightly controlled by the timekeepers of
Miss minutes their authorship is on
everything it's a pretty big deal for he
remains to allow some other employee to
retain visible authorship on anything
this important because people would
start asking around well who's this Ora
Boris guy and why are we worshiping the
timekeepers and not him like think about
how pissed off Eduardo saern was when
Mark Zuckerberg and Sean Parker removed
his name from the Facebook maste
head my name's on the Mast head you
might want to check again now I am aware
the social network is a fictionalized
version of what actually went down in
Facebook but I chose to believe this
conversation was word for word
transcript because it's awesome for he
remains to allow any other worker at the
TVA original authorship over something
he and Miss minut put so much work into
telling all TVA workers was actually the
brainchild of some timekeepers suggests
that he remains must respect and or fear
or aoris now I won't go as far to say OB
is a villain I don't think it's as
simple as him just being the big bad
like kiwi Kuan is not the guy you would
cast for that I think he's more of a
chaotic neutral tenur employee at the
agency and I think what happened was in
that brief conversation between Mobius
and OB Mobius was actually doing a bit
of joky word play that he was actually
the OG and he said something like well
since you're the OG you should really be
OB and that OB is the true he who
remains of the TVA someone the Kang
variant version of he remains knows that
he cannot do this without now I would
actually sooner call Obie a God or a
cosmic entity based on his descent from
the heavens and the shot he was revealed
in maybe even some human Avatar of eon
the Marvel time deity whose statue we
saw in Thor love and thunder or aoris is
the snake eating its own tail a flat
circle a mythological concept that is
linked iny beliefs with yorman Gander
the snake from Norse mythology that
circles to Earth and eats its own tail
either way OB with a name like Orab
Boris truly has no beginning and no end
so why does OB remember Mobius but no
one remembers OB because either the Kang
variant of he who remains doesn't want
to wipe his memory or he who remains is
physically unable to wipe his memory
because OB is on a higher tier of power
than he is now I don't know if this
season of Loki will go as far to assign
OB any proper noun identities from the
pages of Marvel Comics because yeah I've
been misto before and I've learned my
lesson but I do think we're going to
learn that OB is a kind of unkillable
incorrupt forever person an angel you
might say immune to he remains wrath or
his charms and as long as there is an OB
there will be a time variance Authority
hey it's Loki season here at new rock
stars with our in-depth Easter egg
breakdowns coming every week after
episodes drop and on Sundays a new sneak
peek format follow me at eaos thanks for
watching and bye
[Music]
y'all
la